hello everyone this next game was played
in 1989 between the Belarusian
Grandmaster Bicks recuperate chick and
the Brazilian Grandmaster Jamie Neto and
this game has a reputation of being one
of the wildest games ever played so
let's see this wild game
we have efore by Victor c5 the Sicilian
defense Knight to c3 and now the
Brazilian Grandmaster place k-6
we have 9 2 s 3 and we have b5 so quite
an opening choice by the Brazilian
Grandmaster we have B for C captors on
d4 Knight captures on d4 and different
to b7 and ok this Bishop on b7 is a very
strong piece now but developing this
light square bishop early in the game
will cause the wall the black King to
stay in the center for a bit long that's
longer than he should have
we have Bishop to d3 e 6 white castles
and the Queen to c7 and here we have
Queen to e2 we have a knight to c6
Knight captures on c6 Queen captures on
c6 and now a for all white wants to open
up some lines for attacking since the
black king is still in the center we
have B 4 and now of course why doesn't
retreat the 90 plays Knight to d5
because well the knight cannot be
captured if if for example he kept 475
then chapter 75 and the black was the
queen since check from the Queen only 2
so after Knight to d5 we have a knight
to f6 and our y place the Bishop to c4
adding protection to this V 5 square
Bishop to d6 and I look to D 1
what isn't really worried about black
castling King side because if black
tries to castle now for example black
castles
white will just capture the night with
check we had G captures on f6 and our
bishop page 6 and the black loses the
rook
because if black tries to move around
simply Queen to g4 check fall by Queen
to g7 checkmate so after this rook to d1
black played as Bishop to c5 and this is
the world this is an amazing position
because black doesn't want to Castle
kingside but white would really enjoy it
for black castles King side and now
white plays a move that's totally well
if he totally doesn't allow black to
Castle kingside he plays Bishop to h6
and he's threatening to grab this g7
pawn and if if the bishop is captured
and simply Knight captures NSX would
check and probably the best move for
black here would be the capture the
knight Knight captures on d5 and after
eek after sandy five with an attack on
the queen a queen the c8 grabbing this
pawn on g7 and after Roby g8 well white
is better here but black might have
found some compensation with this with
the strong bishop eyeing the g2 and also
with an open G file but after Bishop h6
of like said I don't want to have
anything to do with the Kings side I
mean it's looking really ugly there I'm
going to play a castles Queen side so
okay black Castle queenside and here
white immediately jumps into the attack
he plays Bishop to b5 and okay this is
attacking a queen and well-liked and of
course captured a bishop but the queen
has nowhere to go she can go to d6 but
this is putting your queen in front of
the rook
so which reflect will have to do
eventually but he decides to grab a
piece before that so we'd have a capture
some b5 a capture some b5 and now Queen
to d6 and the whites temporarily wins
the beats back he plays Knight captures
and f6 opening up the attack on the
Queen we have Queen to f8 and our Bishop
captures and g7 we have Queen captures
from g7 and now Queen to C for attacking
this Bishop on c5 and well if this
bishop falls and made Mesa soon to
follow
we have d6 by black and now another
beautiful move by why she plays rook
captures on d6 and well the threat is of
course again capturing this Bishop and
if if rooks captures wrote and simply
Queen captures and c5 would check and
the King cannot get anywhere near the
rope to protect him so this will be over
quickly so after after this rook
captures on d6 move black stride Queen
to g5 now defending this Bishop from g5
but again why it plays a while movie
plays Knight to d5 and now cutting off
Queens protection of this Bishop on c5
Black's captured the night with the
captures on d5 but even in black
captures the rug
again Queen casters on c5 and well
there's this knight on d5 now so if you
could even check on c7 and then grab the
rook so we have eg after Sun d5 and now
Queen captures on c5 with check King
Tubby eight and it seems like blacks
survived this attack and he is up a
piece and well like it doesn't really
need a lot of moves for example Ruby g8
and already black is on the attack and
well white does have this Queen to a7
check but after King gets eight there's
really not a lot of moves for white to
play but white manages to find another
brilliant move and he plays rook to c6
and after after Victor played this work
to c6 his opponent resigned because this
is this is a beautiful move as now the
rook rook protects well the C file here
and the thread is of course the Queen
Queen to a7 checkmate and there is no
stopping this if if for example Bishop
was captured orokin c6 is in simply
Queen t7 check King to c8 and B captures
on c6 and there is no stopping checkmate
on b7 ok blacks could try something like
we're up to 8 but then simply Queen to
d7 and while the King back this is again
checkmate so yeah after this after this
route to c6 move black resigned and well
it's a beautiful game a miniature at
that 23 moves so yeah that's it I do
hope you enjoy this wild game and I do
hope you enjoyed watching the simplest
rapid and blitz tournament 11 Aragon
really want the entire thing like a boss
both rapid on the blade section and he
was actually two points in the lead
before the tournament ended so he he had
first place secured two rounds before
the tournament ended but nevertheless he
won his last two games so so quite an
achievement definitely and I am
interested if if any of you have have
seen Gary's masterclass or if any of you
are thinking about purchasing it I
haven't seen it I only saw the
advertisement for it and you know I'd
like to know what it's about so and
that's it think all for watching as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here and I will see you soon